Welcome to the Man of Recaps,
this is Attack on Titan,
the final episode.
Our protagonist, Eren Yeager,
has now become the final villain.
To protect his home, the island of Paradis,
from the outside world,
He's unleashed the million Colossal Titans
that made up the walls
to kill every other person on the planet.
But now all of our main characters
from Paradis and Marley,
have banded together to stop him!
The last part ended as Eren's friends
leapt from the plane
for a final fight on Eren's
giant new skeletal body.
Plan A is to take out
Zeke the Beast Titan,
so Reiner, the Armored Titan, transforms
and knocks out him immediately.
The hope is without Zeke's royal blood,
Eren will lose his control over
the Eldian founder, Ymir.
Unfortunately, this wasn't the real Zeke,
it was just a construct,
his real body is hidden from them.
So it's on to Plan B,
where Armin will use the explosive power
of the Colossal Titan
to nuke this whole thing.
But Eren planned for this, so whoa!
Armin is immediately
swallowed and taken off the board.
So it's onto Plan C, where
Pieck, the Cart Titan
will strap some dynamite to Eren's head
and blow it up the old fashioned way.
But oh! She's impaled,
by another titan construct Eren’s made.
Yeah he's got a whole army of them,
every titan warrior that's ever lived,
including their old friends
like Bertholdt.
Now for Plan D, there is no Plan D,
they're just desperately fighting to survive,
and very quickly, things look bleak.
But now who's this flying in?
Our gang is picked up by a
giant bird titan!
Yeah remember little Falco
just got the power of the Jaw Titan,
and for some reason,
his manifested as a bird.
With a bird's eye view, Mikasa spots
the weird cow titan that swallowed Armin,
so it's slingshot
time as she's trying to get him.
And it's fight round two, where all
our characters get their own hero moment.
But they're still just too outnumbered,
until, one of the construct titans
turns on the others!
Wait, is that our old friend Ymir?!
While Armin’s unconscious,
his mind is in the Eldian Coordinate,
where he hangs out with Zeke,
who's basically given up on life.
But Armin convinces him
humanity's worth saving,
without humans,
you wouldn't have baseball.
And the spirits of our other titan
warrior friends are here too,
so it's like, “I know you guys are dead,
but we could really use your help.”
So all our dead titan friends
wake up and switch sides,
and now Mikasa is able to rescue Armin!
And Zeke wakes up too, “Here I am, come kill me.”
And Captain Levi, who's killed
the Beast Titan a dozen times,
finally puts him to rest for good.
And it works! The Rumbling stops.
But Eren himself is still a problem.
So it's Jean who swings in there,
grabs the detonator,
blows Eren's head clean off!
Which reveals the weird
jellyfish vertebrae thing
that is the founding Titan.
So now it's time for Eren's best friend Armin,
“Sayonara, Eren.”
Kaboom! Nukes the whole thing!
But of course it's not going to be
that easy.
Eren reforms in a more normal titan body.
The jellyfish thing
survived the blast too,
and now it farts out a
bunch of titan-creating gas,
transforming all the Eldians into titans!
Leading the attack to reconnect with Eren.
So it's the final battle!
Titan punch, hyah!
But Mikasa is sitting this fight out,
she can't bring herself to kill Eren.
In fact she envisions the life
they could have had,
if he didn't become a genocidal maniac.
But he did. So Mikasa accepts
what she has to do...
Swings on in there, into this new titan's mouth
to find Eren's prime body
and cuts his head off! Mikasa kills Eren!
She gently takes his severed head
and gives it a smooch.
Yes, of course,
she's always loved him.
But before Eren died, with the power
of the Eldian Coordinate,
he’s able to have a final chat with his friends
to explain his motivations.
And turns out he wanted
his friends to kill him!
His real plan was to become
an apocalyptic threat,
so Paradis and Marley could unite
against a common enemy.
And with the island Eldians
saving the world from him,
the rest of the world would accept them
and they could finally have peace.
So Eren Yeager really was good all along!
...Well, his motivations at least.
He did in fact kill 80%
of the world's population.
Armin’s like, “Man, I'm sure
there was a better way.”
But our best bros talk it out,
realize both their hands
are stained with blood.
So it's like, “I love you, man.
See you in hell.”
So back in reality, Armin and Mikasa
mourn their best friend Eren,
now that they understand
his real intentions.
And with Eren’s death,
the jellyfish monster disappeared.
It has something to do with
the founder Ymir
getting over her abusive relationship
with the old Eldian king Fritz?
Which means the power of the titans
is gone from the world,
all our Eldians transform back!
And the original dream of the Scouts,
a world without titans,
is finally realized.
Now they've just got
humans to contend with,
and Marley might want to seek retribution.
But Eren's plan seems to work,
as Armin says,
“Yo, we just saved your butts.”
“I think that proves
we're not your enemies.”
So Eren Yeager caused
a near apocalyptic event,
but humanity will eventually rebuild,
and the future looks bright.
A few years later, our crew
returns to Paradis Island,
which, still under control of the Yeagerists,
has become even more militaristic.
But Armin is optimistic
that peace talks will work.
Mikasa is not with them,
she went home earlier
to bury Eren's head
under their favorite tree.
She bids farewell to Eren,
the man she loved but had to kill.
And that's where Attack on
Titan comes to an end.
Except for the credits scene,
which shows the world did go through
an era of peace and prosperity.
But eventually it seems humans
found another reason to kill each other.
And after seemingly destroying
civilization again,
a young child finds Eren's tree,
which has grown enormous.
In fact it looks similar to when Ymir found
the jellyfish Founding Titan originally,
so maybe Titans will come
back in the world? Who knows?
If you liked this recap,
hit that subscribe button
for more of the best recaps
of TV and movies.